[Music]
on the slight chance that kim jong-un
does eventually develop the technology
to attack i have a plan to protect us
okay yes
wow
incredible
thanks for assuming this is real it is a
it's a well-known fact that kim jong-un
loves american sports clothing and pop
culture that is a fact
and it's his love american culture
that's going to save us with my plan let
me explain
first to defend california i've taken
kim jong-un's friend dennis rodman
hostage i plan to use him as a human
shield
in fact we're moving robin to a
different california city every hour
that means he could be anywhere so if
kim jong-un bombs any part of california
he'll be risking the life of his idol
dennis rodman next the pacific northwest
kim jong-un loves to play xbox so he
can't destroy microsoft's headquarters
in seattle he also loves anything nike
which is based in oregon that secures
the entire western seaboard but we will
not stop there
kim jong-un also likes to get his
haircut at supercuts which has over 2
000 locations in the united states he
also likes to shop at the jcpenney young
men's suit department which is
nationwide finally kim jong-un is
overweight and suffers from hypertension
and diabetes which means he probably
loves to visit water parks and we have a
lot of water parks
that secures almost the entire usa
except for one weak spot florida
kim jong-un if you're watching there are
no super cuts j.c penney's nike stores
water parks or dennis rodman's in
florida
florida i'm sorry
what
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
that's nice
clearly nobody here from florida all
right